[Aplausos]
é descobrir renata com 156 anos de idade
foi no momento que eu estava na minha
como estudante de pré e eu tinha que
escolher a pessoa mais bonita da sala de
aula
eu escolhi o menino mais bonito da sala
de aula e ali naquele momento
cobrei que as pessoas me olharam com um
andar de estranheza como se estivesse
errada e era uma coisa aqui pra mim é a
amais pureza que eu tinha dentro do meu
coração e não conseguimos definir com a
qualidade enfim aos nove anos eu me
apaixonei
os amores platônicos eu escrevi uma
carta para esse menino
só que eu nunca cheguei entregar essa
carta e ficou guardada no meio dos meus
livros é a minha mãe me teve com 18 anos
já sofre a única e ela achou essa kata
quando ela só sakata ela começou a ler
pra mim e nakata falava claramente que
era um menino que eu estava gostando
a minha mãe sempre tiveram gays na minha
casa enfim
mas é quando criança pensava que todos
os games virariam mulheres é um exemplo
meio roberta close enfim se do santos
mas eu não entendia eles serem homem ele
se achava eles mail fracassados tipo
envergonhados de serem mulheres
porque pra mim um homem gustavo é a
quando você descobre gay seria virar
mulher não existia essa grandiosidade
que é hoje em dia né
e n case e mulheres e em transe enfim e
daí quando minha mãe perguntou é porque
tava tudo no gênero masculino
eu menti pra ela eu falei que na verdade
era um engano ele não era um era uma
aquilo dentro de mim é me magoou muito
comigo não pela mentira não mas por
estar me prendendo aqui dentro sabe por
não conseguir soltar aquilo que a minha
mãe quebrá no começo da vida a que mais
representa é a sua mãe né
e daí aos 13 anos ela bem a falecer
quando eu perdi minha mãe eu senti que
não tinha mais barreiras não tinha mais
para com que ter medo né eu estava na 7ª
8ª série era presidente de grêmio do
colégio
só que daí nas férias eu voltei loira
voltei loira com escutados
só perdi meu melhor amigo perdi a minha
rede social de amigos até que
compartilhavam comigo aquele momento de
trabalho é grupo né
e nisso eu senti que na verdade eu tinha
era aquele momento que eu precisava me
exteriorizar sabe mostrar pra sociedade
o que eu era o meu pai ele tinha um
grande momento na verdade que eu fosse
trânsito na legenda que essa palavra
engloba né que é o submundo à
prostituição
tudo aquilo que as pessoas acham que é
uma tranquila e que na verdade somos que
nem aqui como qualquer outra pessoa né
e daí ele tinha medo dos tapas que eu ia
levar na vida não o que os tapas que ele
ia me dar enfim ele não me deu ele falou
eu te amo eu te amar sempre
independentemente e graças a deus a
minha família maravilhosa e por isso
estou aqui também
aí aos 13 anos é o de morar com a minha
avó
morei com a minha avó até os 18 anos eu
comecei a trabalhar na noite em são
paulo e comecei a fazer uns jobs com
moda porque mesmo querendo fugir da
história de todo gay é cabeleireiro o
maquiador ou trabalha com moda eu gostei
gostei muito de imagem
sempre achei interessante fotografia
sempre gostei de cheia e sempre gostei
de modelagem eu sempre tive muita sorte
de ter bons amigos e eles foram me
indicando lugares certos
mas mesmo assim ainda tinha aquela
dúvida sobre aonde eu me encaixo sabe é
que eu sou eu sou andrógina apenas
maguey eu sou apenas trânsito apenas com
andré ser né acho que a gente sempre
busca na verdade o que a gente é
acho que isso é uma loucura porque na
verdade você busca o que você é
pelo outro e não por você né você na
verdade você já sabe que você é que as
pessoas que pedem uma explicação sobre
isso e não tem explicação
aos 18 anos
eu ia parar de receber a pensão que eu
tinha pela morte da minha mãe e eu
precisava pagar as minhas contas
eu falei pronto encerrou na ti po voltei
que ser uma garota de programa
nada contra tenho várias amigas e todas
maravilhosas
mas eu não sabia jogar esse jogo eu
chamo de presentes e presentes de deus
que esse aqui até hoje é um presente de
deus presente do universo enfim é um
presente estar aqui
e foi o que eu tive aos 18 anos que foi
trabalhar com uma artista plástica e ela
tava abrindo uma loja trabalha com ela
durante cinco anos e ela me ensinou
basicamente tudo na minha vida ainda me
ensinou a ser o que eu sou
trabalhei com ela durante cinco anos é
me transformei uma vendedora de varejo é
muito boa tinha prazer em vender sabe
que eu não vendi uma coisa que não ia
ficar bem você eu tinha conseguia ter a
sua intimidade
isso foi durante anos assim sabe tipo só
que chegou um momento que você tem que
virar e falar oque vento e tá tudo certo
consigo pagar as minhas contas
mas e agora né você sair um pouco da da
zona de conforto ali é você se
redescobrir na eu cheguei no meu pai
mais uma vez
e perguntei pra ele e perguntei eu já
falei 'pai eu vou pedir demissão do meu
emprego
trabalhava em uma marca muito bem
consolidada no mercado de varejo eles
assustou a princípio foi o mesmo mas
está com 30 anos né que vai fazer enfim
eu passei três meses respirando né só
que no primeiro mês eu respeitei muito
bem no segundo mês é as contas não
paravam de chegar
um amigo meu que tem uma agência de
comunicação humana e mail pra ele
falando olha o trabalho com moda já
conheço as mídias conheço os produtores
né esse mercado é isso que eu gosto de
fazer isso que quando acima de tudo você
tem que descobrir o que você gosta de
fazer
porque perrengue você vai ter em
qualquer lugar
o que vai fazer a diferença é o seu amor
por aquilo né
e daí ele respondeu é me dando um
emprego de produção de moda numa agência
que eu queria muito trabalhar mas é
mesmo assim eu ainda não me encaixava em
todas aquelas bolhas e rótulos que são
dados e não me encaixo hoje em dia
também porque não vou dizer que não sou
ativista não participou de nenhuma ong
pró transpirar homossexuais enfim meu
ativismo ele é o acordar ele é existir
ele é olhar no espelho e ver que eu tô
bem e que está tudo certo que vou ter
que fazer uma escova vou ter que não
fazer enfim uma pessoa normal é você
andar pela rua e receber esse feedback
mas saber filtrar ele né porque nem toda
opinião do outro é importante para você
né
então eu acho que na verdade
hoje em dia eu estou com 34 anos
trabalhos a com essa mesma agência
fazendo o que eu amo
não fui pelo óbvio sabe não foi pela
coisa que as pessoas se acostumam de
colocar a falar olha você é branca out
loira você vai ser modelo
a você é negro do morro você vai ser
jogador de futebol
não eu acho que o óbvio é você que faz é
você que acredita nele e se você não
encontra a sua bolha você não encontra o
seu rótulo crie um acredite em você
tenha isso o maior devedor da sua vida
sabe onde pra você descobrirá atrás
daquilo que você quer porque só assim
você vai conseguir ser feliz porque com
os outros não é assim
é isso é um prazer estar aqui
são histórias vinda
obrigada por eu estar aqui e fazer parte
disso
[Aplausos]